all right so Pinocchio has been the hot
ticket IP the last couple of years with
animated and live action adaptations but
Netflix and Guillermo del Toro might
have the best of the best on their hands
with the latest stop-motion animation
musical take on the character which
differs quite a bit from the
stereotypical Pinocchio story you've
grown to know so in this video we're
going to talk about del Toro's
inspiration for the story how the ending
differs some of its themes along with
our reaction and review of this latest
wooden boy turned human or or something
kind of in the middle Pinocchio movie
now if you enjoy this video then hit
that like button as it helps the channel
I would not lie and also don't forget to
subscribe for breakdowns Recaps and
other videos like this every day with
that out of the way a huge thank you for
clicking this I'm your host Jared now
let's get into Guillermo del Toro's
Pinocchio
[Music]
now like I mentioned up top del Toro's
Pinocchio differs quite a bit from the
other house of mouse versions that you
grew up with you know with Geppetto
Wishing Upon a Star the wooden Boy comes
to life and the pair get into all sorts
of scrambles
[Music]
when can I leave
dad completely different from that
version as well instead Del Toro adapted
Grizz grimley's designs from his 2002
edition of the 1883 Italian novel The
Adventures of Pinocchio by Carlo claddy
and after looking at some of the
illustrations of his book Del Toro
brought this into 3D stop-motion
flawlessly like even the puppet scenes
here that are at the carnival are ripped
directly from the book as for the 1883
Italian novel yes it does contain some
of the familiar elements from the big
budget adaptations of Pinocchio you may
be used to but with a slight twist Del
Toro simply uses the novel as a template
keeping some things while crafting his
own unique take with other parts
Geppetto Pinocchio his nose growing a
cricket the carnival and giant Dogfish
instead of a whale are all carried over
Del Toro then adds a bit of
Frankenstein's monster Flair to
Pinocchio but one of the biggest changes
implemented is the setting of 1930s
Italy set during the Great War or rather
World War II at this time Italy is under
fascist Rule and plays into many of the
iconic Pinocchio moments such that
Geppetto's son Carlo died in a bombing
which drives him to alcoholism and then
building Pinocchio this is a children's
movie right the young boys don't go off
to some Island and become donkeys but
rather go into a fascist Youth
Organization Camp because get this they
think Pinocchio will make the perfect
Soldier because he can't die and the
ocean scenes feature dozens of Naval
mines that later dispatched the giant
Dogfish Del Toro clearly has something
to say likening this to how children
watch the original Disney adaptation and
were to learn right from wrong his
version though is for children and
adults to do the same he even includes
Benito Mussolini to not only fit the
time setting but to hilariously Riff on
him now the ending is something I did
not expect but does tie in with the more
realistic raw hey this is a tragedy of
life my dude approach so the dogfish has
exploded into a million pieces of sushi
sending Pinocchio and the Gang soaring
resulting in the wooden boy dying for a
third time Pinocchio chooses to leave
the underworld early in order to save
Geppetto from drowning therefore trading
in his infinite lives to become mortal
this is the movie's take on the I'm a
real boy now moment with him returning
and saving Geppetto however in this
selfless act Pinocchio drowns and dies
the Wood Sprite shows up again
apologizing to Geppetto that she really
only wanted to bring him Joy which
Pinocchio did but now it's sorrow as
Geppetto pleads with her to bring him
back but reveals Pinocchio gave his own
life to save Geppetto's Jay Cricket
chimes in stating it's not fair that she
had promised him one single wish if he
had looked over Pinocchio and made sure
he was a good boy and to do what was
right sure Cricket messed up a bit but
Pinocchio turned out to be better than a
good boy and in turn taught Cricket what
it was to be good the Wood Sprite sees
Cricket had accomplished what she had
originally asked for and wishes
Pinocchio back to life with the same
spell she used in the beginning Geppetto
admits he learned something too he
shouldn't have been trying and trying to
make Pinocchio into something he wasn't
he shouldn't have to be like Carlo or
anyone else but exactly who you are one
of the glaring main themes flowing
through the story as Pinocchio comes
back to life Cricket spasitura Geppetto
and Pinocchio all celebrate his return
acknowledging life is such a wonderful
gift and a wonderful gift it is as
slowly one by one Geppetto Cricket
spasitura pass away with Pinocchio being
there for their final moments the two
are buried next to Carlos grave and
Cricket in a Black Bunny Matchbox living
in Pinocchio's heart what happens
happens and then we are gone as we see
another pristine Pinecone fall off of
the tree
I'm not crying you you are
now del Toro's Pinocchio does have a
mid-credit scene so don't get up off
your couch and walk away just yet as we
see Sebastian J Cricket in the afterlife
playing cards with the black rabbits
that were featured a handful of times
when Pinocchio kept dying it's a quick
final check-in with the character and if
you could guess the entire story is
actually him recounting his life to the
black rabbits hence him being the you
know narrator of the whole movie it's a
fun final nod to the care character but
the reoccurring joke of Jay cricket
being interrupted before what's that no
no I'm telling everyone about the you
know mid-credit scene where Jay Cricket
is revealed
I see what you're doing but Cricket
finally gets his time to shine singing
his song that he had been interrupted
time and time again while featuring his
excellent dance moves where's Pinocchio
to throw it down too I will admit
despite this adaptation being in
development hell for roughly a decade it
was well worth the wait and completely
stands alone from other adaptations of
the property mainly because of its
stop-motion animation the absolute
detail like like the count having a long
pointy nose because he's also lying all
the time and small mannerisms of the
characters and environments were
seamless I had many times completely
forgot that this whole team had to rig
this up and meticulously move everything
centimeters to create this work of art
another thing that makes this feel so
unique is the times setting and events
that Del Toro chose to feature ballsy is
one way I'll describe it especially the
spotlight of the rise of fascism and
government control which is very much
present still today but it is also
meaningful in multiple ways sure it's an
educational and lighter historical look
at things but also meshes well with the
lessons Pinocchio needs to learn to
become a real boy become obedient in a
sense but also learning to question the
way things are go against the status quo
and realize what is important to a
person and how those relationships can
be lifelong I'm getting real sappy with
things but I gotta give Del Toros
Pinocchio a solid 9 out of 10. like I
said everything is hitting those unique
beats that were very much appreciated
differing itself from the pile of other
pinocchios out there and hit the feels A
Perfect Blend of del Toro's lighter
horror elements like things get dark
yeah I'm not kidding you candlewick's
father try tries to have him shoot
Pinocchio Point Blank combined with the
joyous more light-hearted comedy like
I'm a sucker for a good fart song don't
get me wrong so when Pinocchio was
laying into Mussolini I got a real kick
out of its Terence and Philip stylings
but there are a handful of other comedic
moments that made me laugh like the ship
captain saluting uriva dochi right as
they see the dogfish the voice cast was
spot on as well really added a lot of
Personality Kristoff Waltz he was so
good anyway I'd love to hear your
thoughts on del Toro's Pinocchio what's
the stop-motion approach better than
what anything The Mouse House has been
shoveling out there and I'll let you
know we're currently running the
competition right now giving away three
copies of House of dragons season one on
the 15th of December and all you gotta
do to get a chance of winning this is
like this video make sure to subscribe
with notifications on and drop a comment
down below with your thoughts of
Pinocchio we pick the comments at random
at the end of the month and the winners
of last month are on screen right now so
if that's you message us on Twitter at
heavy spoilers if you want something
else to watch be sure to check out some
of our other cool videos our
Transformers rise of the Beast breakdown
is massive so enjoy but with that out of
the way thank you for your constant
support I've been Jared and remember do
not lie and with that I'll say bye bye
all right take care peace